successful marketing once met big-budget
TV ads great print campaigns and radio
jingles that stuck in your head not
anymore
today 22 percent a video consumption
happens online 57 percent of text
consumption happens online and 67
percent a music consumption happens
online in a world where life has gone
digital digital marketing is no longer
an alternate channel of its own that
businesses can choose to ignore it's
simply how marketing must be done and
there are tons of high quality high
paying jobs out there for the right
candidate The Times of India estimates
there are 150,000 jobs available in
India and indeed calm reports 250,000
jobs in the US now I've been a writer a
speaker and a working professional in
digital marketing for well over a decade
I've also been educating and training
digital markers for many years all
around the world and there are two
questions I've been asked over and over
again what does it take to be a
successful digital marker what's the
best way to get there well there's tons
of people claiming they know digital
marketing engineers who are great at
churning out analytics dumps my friend
Avinash Lux are called datacube SEO s
who promised wild claims of page one
rankings
social media gurus who will sell you
likes PPC expert will be happy to help
you spend too much money at paid
advertising but the reality is knowing
how to send a tweet does that make you a
quarter marketer posting family photos
and Facebook doesn't make you a facebook
marketing strategist' and having a
LinkedIn profile is a long way from
being a true blinked in marketing guru
for anyone getting into the field
whether you're an executive who needs to
understand the basics or a marketing
strategist who needs to guide a team of
professionals or even a specialist who
plans to be really an expert in one or
two core skill sets need a sound
understanding of all the digital
marketing skills and how they work
together that kind of 360-degree
foundation and all the critical
disciplines of digital marketing is
required for any
one who wants to understand and
contribute meaningfully to digital
marketing initiatives you should be
comfortable with how all these
specialties build on one another how
they generate traffic optimizing for
visitor conversions developing valuable
content that your audience will share
and magnify nurturing leads with email
campaigns and paid search using social
media to protect your online reputation
while developing brand trust and
authority and measuring and testing
results to constantly improve your
campaigns what if you're aiming to be a
digital marketing specialist someone
whose job will be to strategize build
implement and measure digital marketing
initiatives that's you you need more
in-depth knowledge to be that kind of
specialist it's critical to cross-train
in two three or four disciplines to do
with the industry calls a t-shaped
marketer someone who has a broad working
knowledge of all the skill sets and then
a deep knowledge of one or a few
specialties those marketers with a deep
specialized understanding in their areas
of expertise will lend the best roles
can earn up to 90% more than their
generals colleagues so what's the best
way to get there according to Adobe
ninety percent of large organizations
feel that their digital marketing team
is weak in one or more areas a digital
marketing yet only 46% of companies are
going to invest in developing the
digital skills other teams instead
companies are looking for experts who
are already have a developed
understanding of digital marketing so
how can you be the expert they're
looking for well for entry-level digital
marketing roles digital marketing
managers or even those whose business
roles that aren't required digital
marketing heavy lifting our DMCA course
should provide everything you need a
high quality training plan a couple of
hands-on projects that will get you
industry ready in just six weeks with
DMCA certification on your belt you'll
have that broad cross discipline
foundation we talked about to be able to
communicate with all the stakeholders
set realistic expectations with
achievable goals and be part of a
holistic team that works together
efficiently to maximize the impact of
your marketing and grow your business
know the other hand if your goal is to
that t-shaped digital marketing
specialist who is going to lead teams to
strategize and manage digital marketing
initiatives you need more focus and
specialized training so for you I'd
recommend following your dmca training
with more Advanced Study and web
analytics PPC SEO and social media
marketing
imagine having access to a structure
multi-step training program designed by
industry experts to provide you the
skills you need to excel at the job
training that teaches you not just the
foundations but gives you that deep dive
into mastering the strategies and
tactics of your chosen discipline and
empowers you to innovate and create the
effective digital campaigns your company
deserves imagine getting live expert
mentoring and project work that can give
you the hands-on experience the industry
demands does that sound like the
training you need that's what I have
worked with simply learn to create it's
our digital marketing specialist
master's program the most effective way
to be a complete digital marketer
you